これはこの神速としてどんな神速かというと
ローバディッティマーナという三つがありましたね
不善心所の中で欲のセットの中
不善心所十四ありまして
見ですね そこにローバディッティマーナという三つのセットは貪りのセットなんです
そこで二番目は瞋と言ってディッティと呼んで
このディッティという心素なんです
邪見という間違っている考え方ということなんです
このディッティ 間違っている考え方は誰にでもあります
誰の考え方も正しいわけじゃないんです
で それはまたガンカーになっちゃうんです
ガンカーになっちゃったら
スィーラッパタ・パラマーサになります
ガンも一種類じゃないんだからね
体のガンにしてもいろんな種類がありますからね
で スィーラはもう一応戒律の戒であって
またはいろいろ行がありますね
世の中に それにはものすごく囚われる
どのように囚われるかというと
やっぱり何か修行らしきものはしなきゃいけないと
というふうな心にあるんです
いくら瞑想したっても
座禅の方がかっこいいと
なぜならばすごいしきたりがあるんです
座り方 目の置き方 手の置き方
もの全部厳密に決まってるんですね
だからこの形決まってるんだから
それは行ですね それは修行と認める
形決まってないと認めない
で ご飯食べる場合も 人は何か特別なものを食べているならば
大根おろしとご飯しか食べてないんだと
他の人はまあチキンも食べてるんだと
そうするとどうせみんな誰が本当の宗教かといえば
必ずと選挙で勝つのは大根とご飯食べる人なんです
そこで人気投票したならば
二人の同じ宗派で同じ年の同じ能力を持ってる二人が
じゃあ人気投票したならば
一人が草履履いていると
もう一人は裸足で歩いていると
誰が勝つんですかね その心の働きなんですね
こちらで言っているのは
仏教ではそういう形式的なことをものすごく笑ってるんです
そういうのは ただ笑ってるだけで
別にああだこうだって言ってるわけじゃないんだけど
あの まああまりそんなことで意味がないんだと
インドだったらね 必ずしもガンジス川に入って水浴びをしないと罪が綺麗にならないんですね
隅田川に入ってもダメなんです
罪はそのまんま 川も隅田川だからね
で やっぱりガンジス川の遺体流している
みんな便所にも使っている
その川に入らなきゃいけないんですね
だからそういうふうなことも
まあこれに入っちゃうんですね
なぜかというと このインド人みんなある一箇所に集まらなくちゃ
もう救いの道がないんだからね
ガンジス川でもどこでもいいわけじゃないんです
川を二つ繋げるところあるでしょう
そこで三つあるんだと
一つは頭の中しかないんだけどね
インド人の そこでもうこの川二つ合流するところで水に入らなくちゃいけないんです
不思議なことにお釈迦様が悟り開いたのはそのそばなんです
歩いていけるんです うん
そういう風な人々をいろいろこのしきたりやらね
まあちょっとした普段やらない変なことを修行だと
そういうことをしなきゃもう心は清らかにならないとものすごく思っている
その考え方あるならば
もう悟りということはもう完全に不可能なんです
こういうふうに歩かなくちゃいけないんだとかね
こういう色の服を着なくちゃいけないんだとかね
こういうふうに食べ物を食べなくちゃいけないんだとかね
滝行をやらなくちゃいけないんだとかね
インドのこの苦行をやる場合はね
あのジャイナ教なんかでもヒンドゥー教もやってるんでしょうと思いますけど
この板に釘を打つんです
というわけで それで草履にするんです
言って 草履の底ですか
足に触れるところは全部釘なんです
そこで歩くんでね 歩くたびに痛いんですけどね
まあたくさん釘を打ってるんだからね
別にもう怪我するっていうことはないんですけどね
怪我はしないんだけど
やっぱりかなり危ないし
かなり痛いし で 昔ジャイナ教の人々は今もそうでしょうと思いますけどね
出家する場合は髪の毛を一本一本抜くんです
剃るんじゃなくて だからすごい盛大な宗教的なおまじないをやって
そこで出家する人はまずこの人の髪の毛を一本一本一本一本抜く
それで痛いんですね それはもう修行です
聞いた話で痛いだけじゃなくて
どんどんどんどん抜くと血も出始めちゃうんだと
そこで灰ありますね 時にそれ灰でこの全部もう孤児死するんですね
それでさらに痛いんですね
清めはそれでやっちゃうんです
まあそちらの言われ方の個しかわかりませんだけど
まあこの一次出家の場合はもうタイミャンマーはやらないとわかるんですよ
見たことはないんだからね
僕らの場合 一次出家ないんだからね
で 一生で一生の出家だからね
清めがあるんです 髪の毛剃った後で
清めるという儀式のようなものありますけど
まあそれでもサイクルは終わりと
で でも 痛いことは何もしません
その時もある植物の使いますけど
皆様のカレーに使う黄色いあれ
あれ物あるでしょ あれの生のやつ
形はこのあれと似てます
生姜と似ていますね 生姜と似ています
あれはもう最高な殺菌作用あるんです
で いろんなところでこのいろいろ
あの カビとか生えてすごい臭い時あるでしょう
あれちょっと剃って水にちょっと溶かして置いておくと
もう 5分以内で全部綺麗に香りが綺麗になってしまうので
ものすごい力強いんです
ですから あれは全然痛くも唐辛子と違うんです
全く痛くもないんだけど
ですから頭を剃った瞬間で初めて子供たちの頭剃っちゃいますからね
子供たちももういろいろね
細菌に抵抗力もないし
ですからあれで清めた方が安全安全だなと思いますけど
それで あの 何もね 腫れることも痛くなることもなく
もうちゃんと殺菌作用がありますけど
今もそれほど厳密にはやりませんね
僕らの時代ではすごく厳密に清めなくちゃいけないんだと
また悪口まで言いながらからかいながらね
お前らは臭いんだと だからもうこうやって清めなきゃ
もうこれは聞かせてあげませんとか何とか言いながらもやりますけど
まあジャイナ教の清めっていうのは針を縫うと
あれはすごくかなり痛いと思いますけど
で そういう風ないろいろ儀式
修行とかね まああったりして
で そうしなきゃいけないと
で そういう人間の心の中で本来持っている感情があるんですね
それは仏教だからといって消えているわけじゃないんです
で もう千日行修行とかね
念仏を唱えながら 1ヶ月間座ることも寝ることもなく
あのどこでしたっけ？なんとかさんとかだったと思う
もうずっと行をやってるとかね
あれすごい厳しい苦行なんですね
で じゃあ 1ヶ月間もう全く寝ないで泊まることもなく
で 歩きながら念仏を唱える
それでどんどん倒れるんだから
後ろからお世話役の人々は支えているんです
体がね すごい尊い行だと
あれ悟りますかね 悟りますかね
疲れますけどね 疲れます
倒れますということはありますけどね
悟りますということは
まあもう全くないんですね
で あの なんでこういうことを言いますか
で これなんで これアビダンマの中にもなんか他人の宗教批判することではないかと
非科学的ではないかと思う可能性もありますけど
そうじゃないんです で
そんな行ではなくて 悟れるっていうことは
物事は現象であって 瞬間瞬間変化するものだと
何一つも一定している個体的なものがないんだと
そこに実体も何もないんだと
ということを分かったところで
心は自由になるんですね
それが悟りというんですね
その立場から見ると そちらの働きは反対なんですね
何かに行に囚われる これ
他己行に囚われたんだから
どうやって無常を見られますかね
どうやって一切は現象であると分かりますかね
幻覚は起こるかもしれません
大体念仏やるとかなり幻覚起こるんですね
まあ 3日間寝ないでやっちゃうとね
まあ結構幻覚起こると思います
で すっごく頭が働く人はそんなことやりませんだから
抜群に頭を使っている人だったらね
あれ 2日も持たない ものすごい幻覚起こすと思います
もう何もしないでいる人々がね
別に勉強もしないし何もしないし
ですからまあ 1ヶ月間でも我慢して脳は使ってないんだからね
僕の場合はもしかするとこの 1ヶ月間じゃなくて
もう時間 8時間やっちゃうと
いろんな幻覚が出てくる
脳がいろんな混乱を起こしまして
なぜならば いろんなことをやってやって
強力に働いて そういう癖がついているんだから
ですから まあ脳がない人でも
やっぱり 1ヶ月間ぐらいやっちゃうとね
いろいろ幻覚は起こす可能性はもう 99%あります
だから幻覚を起こすこと自体も悟りとは違う世界だから
あの幻想が見た幻想が真理だ
実体だと 勘違いするでしょうね
ですから そのそういう行に囚われる道っていうのは
智慧が現れてくる道とは正反対なんです
ですから 仏教ではこの異常な欲と異常な怒りと一緒に
その修行の世界も入れてるんです
修行を好む気持ちも ですから
わかりやすいです 例えば
世の中でこの欲だけ目指して金だけ儲かることで頑張ってる人々はたまたま失敗するでしょ
人生 失敗しちゃったら突然次の日はどこか道場に差し込むんです
そういうケースよくあるでしょうね
だから急にこのすごい森の中に入って
すごい中に入って 人にも顔を合わせないで修行に入る人々は
社会で何をやっていた人？極力的な欲の世界に入って
もう先頭を取ってチャレンジで頑張ってた人々なんですね
だからそっちでなければこっちという
ただそれだけのことです
あれは決して聖なる道でも
それによって心が清らかになることでも何でもないんです
だから そういうことでよくわかるんです
異常な欲にやられていて
それで失敗しちゃったら
すぐもう次の極端に行こうではないか
そこで体痛めて いろんな修行や
やって まあまたよしなりましたと
また欲の世界に戻る 何人か有名人がいるでしょ
そういうふうに もうすごい恥ずかしいことをやったりしてね
まあ名誉が消えちゃったら
そういうタレント的な仕事できませんから
そこでまた名誉を取り戻しちゃうんですね
ああいうことで だからそんなもの悟りの道じゃないですよ
行く人の小心者の目的はまた仕事に戻るぞということでしょうに
ですから 業っていうのは大体そんなもんなんです
そのようにこの欲をなくす道じゃなくて
違う形ですごい欲を作る道なんです
ですから ヴィパッサナー修行するためにも
どこを行ってもいいんだけど
私はもう一年いるんだ
二年修行するんだとかね
それだけ言われたら行くんだったら
まあ高齢であってね 何もやられないんです
行く前に私は証明書を
免許証を書いてあげることはできます
あなたは何も得られなく帰りますことを心によって証明いたします
だからその日にちとかね
何の関係もないんです
自分がきちんとやって
物事を見て 知恵が現れるように物事を見るか見ないかということは
仏教の道であって 業とは関係ない
だからそういう教則が時々出てくるんです
例えば都会の方から十キロ離れたところに道場があるんだと
そこで例えば友達三人がいたとすると
その友達の間でまた競争心が生まれてきて
そこである友達が二十五十キロ離れたところで
都会から違う道場があるんだけど
じゃあ私はそっち行くんだと
で 中へ行くと それで三番目の人は五百キロ離れた山の上でもう一つ
もう一年中寒い もう零下零度ぐらいのところに道場から私はそこに行くんだとかね
そちらに心の中に隠れているのはこの
これ消えてるんですかね
このカエガンタなんですね
そのシステム これは心のシステム
形で数字で日にちで食べるご飯の質で着る服の色やらあだこだことで
あるいは首にお数珠は首にかけるか
手にかけるか 腰にかけるかと
そんなことで で どれぐらいの聖者のこのメーターそこで測るんですね
ですから あるね あの召使いの女の子がね
あるバラモン人に言ったストーリーあるでしょうね
まあバラモン人が朝早く起きて
太陽が出る前に川に入って
もう三行して罪を全部潔め
これメス買いだから朝早く水を汲みに行っちゃったら
これカプも違うし だからバラモン人が出て行くまでじーっと待っていなくちゃいけないんですね
これ迷惑だから この女の子にとってはね
このバラモン人がカースト一番高いんだからね
まあ一応待っていて で
またまあこれ先生は何をなさっていたんですか？と
すごい威張って 私はもう毎日来て
こういう風に全部罪を洗い流してくんだと
ああそう じゃああなたより先にこのカエルやらね
魚やらメダカやらね あんたより先に天国に行くんですねと
ただそれだけで そこはあの召使いの女の子が悟りより先に悟っていたんだからね
だから厳密に合理主義なんですね
だからすごい行者がただ一言葉でそこで負けてしまっちゃうんです
そこで悪いことをね 解釈するでしょうね
こういう場所は聖地だ
こちらの波動が違うんだ
この水は違うんだとかね
あの木のあの木の気がまた違うんだとかね
そういうもう何の根拠もなく
もういろいろ解釈までして
本まで書いたりして 人の解脱をどのように妨げるかと
解脱しないようにするかと
で もういっぱい世の中にそういうことあるんですね
一つ仏教が軽々く 問題は心にあるということで
なんとか木が見たところですごい尊く感じて感動するんだったら
その木のせいじゃなくて本人のせいなんですね
なぜならばそこにも猿もいるわ
カラスも来てね そこに座るわ
カラスは悟らないわね
残念ながら そこで人々はもうこれは真木だと思うと
そこでなんとかね ある綱をつなげて
死に際ですか 一生懸命拝んで安産できますようにとかね
子供授かりますようにとかね
旦那が早く死にますようにとか
いろいろ願い事を立てたりする
で そういうのはこの行やら戒律やらね
じゃあ戒律って言葉使うなら仏教に戒律はあるんじゃないかと
仏教の中の人もそういうしきたり教じゃないでしょ？嘘言うなと
それはこちらに入らないんです
じゃあ嘘言っていいんですかね
それだったら 宗教関係なく嘘言ってはいけませんだから
殺すなかれと あれは戒律じゃないかと
じゃあ殺してもいいんですかね
それだったら 動物殺すのはいいんですから
なんで人殺すのは良くないんですかね
だから殺生するなかれというと
それに反対する人々言うのは殺生しなきゃ食べられないでしょうとかね
じゃあ殺生いいんですかね
それだったら いいでしょうと
それだからなんで豚を殺すのはよろしいと
でも人間殺すのは良くないと
どういうわけですかね
あれは その男は平気でまるっきりインチキ言うでしょうに
嘘 それは人間に魂があるんだからと
あれほど変な非合理的な
無茶苦茶な くだらない
無意味な話 何の科学もないでしょうに
そこに そういう人々は合理と我々は合理的だ
人間は魚食べてるんだ
豚食べてるんだ 牛食べてるんだ
肉がなければもう食べられないんだとかね
あんた方は殺生をやめなさいと言ったってもね
そんなことでは人類は破滅するんだとか
偉そうに理屈っぽいものを言うんですね
それで はい あなたの理屈正しければもう殺してもいいということでしょうに
それだったら片っ端から殺すぞと
なんで豚肉が食べたら体に良く
何で人間の肉食べて食べるのは悪いんですかね
もっと体にいいでしょうと思いますけど
それは良くないんです
なぜかというと 人間に魂があるんです
いきなりそう言っちゃうんです
だから人間の理屈っていうのは
それってそんな程度のものなんです
だから仏教では殺生するなかれとしてはいけないんだと
そこには そこには動物も人間も
もう生命はすべて入ってるんです
理由は 生命は殺すのは嫌がりますから
それ正しい事実でしょうに
殺してちょうだいという生命はいないでしょうに
ですから それは戒律にこちらには入れません
仏教の戒律は それでまた行も仏教にあります
しきたりもあります そのしきたりは一つもこれ世の中にあるこの修行みたいなものには入りません
仏教の行っていうのは
自分いるところは厳密に綺麗にしなさい
インドではスリランカでもこの南我々の方ではトイレに行ったら必ず水を使う
水を使って体を洗うと
そこであちこち水を散らかすようにするな
厳しいんです あちこち水を流し散らかしておくと
それはもうダメと それだったらすごい丁寧にそこを洗って
綺麗に水で洗って出て行かなくちゃいけないんです
それは行なんです 理由はすごいわかりやすい
みんなに迷惑だから みんな使ってるものだから
ただそれだけ 顔を必ず磨かなくちゃいけないんです
出家の人は 髪の毛は月一回
二回ぐらいは必ず剃らなくてはいけない
そういうのは じゃあ髪を伸ばしてたら地獄に落ちるんですかと言うと
そうじゃないと 醜いんだと
不潔なんだと だから一番簡単に綺麗になるための方法っていうのは髪の毛を剃ることなんです
で 髪の毛を剃ったらもう何のことなくシャンプーもなしに
まあただ体同じ石鹸でもう洗っちゃえばそれで全部終わりなんです
で 今と違って昔いろいろ何とかの髪の毛の中にえ？シラミ？シラミ
出たりするでしょう 今はね
まあ現代はなかなかね
まあないんだけど いまだにいるんですからね
そういうあのね 貧困あるところではね
ですから それどうやってなくせばいいんですかね
ずっと殺生しなくちゃいけないし
それより髪の毛を綺麗に剃ってしまえば
もうシラミは出てこない
シラミの卵は髪の毛で産むんだから
ですから そういうのは一つの行にならない
そういうのはすごい合理的なんです
そういうのは それからそれは悟るためというよりは
社会人として行儀よくいるために必要なもので
そういうのは悟りの障害にはならない
でもだからといって自分の部屋もお寺もまるっきり掃除しようとしない
食べた食器なんかそのまま置いといて
人が修行するったらまた悟れないんです
なぜかと言えば怠け者だから
あれぐらいのことをやりたくない人がものすごい精神的にショックを受ける
精神的に自分の心に爆弾かけるぐらいすごいショックを受ける
修行には励みませんね
ですから 仏教で厳しく
まずそういうのは戒律の世界を済ませておきなさい
戒律と行の方 それで修行に入りなさい
瞑想に入る前に全部飲み水を汲んでおいて
洗うために必要な水を汲んでおいて
全部掃除をして 自分の部屋から森やらね
他の人々が出たり入ったり
お坊さんが出たり入ったりする中では
そちらの人々に必要なものは全部用意しておいて
それから修行に入る いくら瞑想することは一番尊いと言ったっても
そんなことは日常のことをね
おろそかにすると性格はできてない
もともと性格もできてない人には
尊い道にチャレンジは不可能ですから
もうそれはやりなさいと言ってますけど
それとこちらで言ってるこのシーラ・パラミは違うことなんですね
ですから 仏教ではいくら戒律守ったっても
いくら式だり守ったっても
それでは悟れないとということはきちんと知ってるんです
そういうことをやったっても悟りはしませんと
悟りはちゃんと真理を見なきゃ現れないものだということはきちんと知った上でやるものなんです
で 人間にとってはこの過去も現在も
これからも 人間の心にはこの死観があるんです
何か変なことをしたら
それで大変格好いいと
性格はしっかりするんだと
ということはずっと人間の心の中であるんです
性格をしっかりするために
ちゃんと原因究明して
ちゃんと真理を見るべきですとは人間は思わないんです
何か行やらせちゃうんです
例えば学校で子供が言うことを聞かないと
バケツに水を入れて それを持っていなさいと
あれは行やらせること
あれは一つ罰なんですけど
じゃああんなことやったら性格直りますかね
直らない 行やらせたっても
その人の性格を直すためには
その人がなぜ悪いことをしたかと
それでどういう結果になるかと
自分がどういう人間になるべきかということは
納得いかない限りは 子供にはいくらバケツを持っていなさいと言ったっても
性格はそれでは直らないんです
行をやらせたっても そこで性格悪い子にあなたはもう一人で教室を
あの何て言いますか モップで拭きなさいと言われたっても
先生はどうか言ってやったら
どうせ性格悪いんだから他の子供にせかすなてめえがやりなさいと
で やらせる可能性もまたあるし
あるいはもう何か買ってあげるんだからとかね
よく子供はそういうことやるんです
もう罰として何かしなさいと言っちゃったら
それがお前に今度は漫画買ってあげるんだから
やっておけと それでもちゃんとやってくれる
それでも先生はよし 受けてきましたと
で 何の意味もなくなっちゃうんですね
[笑い]僕らにも昔はよく書かせるんですね
英語とかなんとか勉強するって聞いた時はね
ちょっとでもスペリングなんか間違っちゃったら
これはもう百五十回とか何とか
二ページ 三ページぐらい書きなさいと言われて
先生は見るんだから 自分でその場合はね
人にあのもう何て言うの
飴買ってあげるんだから言って書いてもらうわけにいきませんだからね
自分では書くんだけど
全然あれでスペリングは全然覚えられないんです
ただ見てみて 書いて書いて書いて書いて
先生終わった そこで字が悪いし
ある日はね 字が汚いし
それからスペリングも勉強しなきゃいけないということで
先生はそういう勉強には繰り返して書いた方がいいんだと
で 毎日一ページ一ページぐらい書いて書きなさいと言って
毎日先生宿題出してくれるんですね
その時はちゃんと論理的な考え方になるんですね
バツじゃなくて ちゃんと毎日一ページぐらい同じ言葉書けば
まあスペリングはきちんと覚えられるんだと
字も綺麗になるんだと
先生はモデルの行書いてくれるし
それで一回私はこれもう一行書いたしまったところで
それでまあすぐ覚えてしまって
すぐさささっと書いて持っていったんですね
書いて持ってたら 上から下に見ると曲がってるわ
いろいろ字の形が変わってるわと
言ったら先生 それに怒らないで
あなたはね この私が書いた字を見て書いてないんだと
二行目で自分で書いて
自分の二行見て三行目書いたんだと
自分の三行見て四行目書いたんだと
そこでどんどんどんどん変になって
最後になっちゃうなると
これ何書いてるんですか
これは それでは勉強にならないんだと
ですから 次の次は一番下から始めてください
そうすればいつでも私の字を見られるんだと
言われたら何のことなく論理的でしょうに
そこでまあ分かりました
何のことなく もう何の抵抗もなく
なるほど そういうことかと思って
まあそれからそういう風にしたんですね
ですから ただ行やらせただけでいい人になるということじゃないんです
ちゃんとそれの原因を究明して
それなりの道でないといけないんですね
でも 残念なことに 世の中で業好きな人々がもうあまりみんなそういう弱みを持ってるんです
だから最初に私は例で冗談で言ったのはね
人気投票に出たら やっぱり総理はく人と総理はけない人の場合は総理はけない人がもうまあ九十パーセントぐらいは取るんです
ですから 野菜食べたんだからといって心が柔らかくなるわけでもないし
肉食べるんだからといって心がきつくなるわけではないし
やっぱり問題は自分の心にあって
そこを見るべきですよ
それはヴィパッサナーの道
悟りの道ですから その悟りの道と全く違う方向へ人を運ぶシステムだから
戒禁取諸式と言っているんです
いわゆるいいことをしたいという気持ちはあるんです
いいことをしたい しっかりしたいという気持ちはあるんだけど
それでひどい目に遭ってしまっちゃうんです
ですから 番目はこのシーラッブとパーラーナーサというシステム
番目はもっと大事なんです
これイダン・サッチャー・ヴィニレーサ
これなかなかこのこちらでしか出ない言葉なんです
このガンタというところでしか出てこない言葉なんです
イダン・サッチャー・ヴィニレーサ
これもすっごい人類にあるんですね
これは一番ありがちなガンです
心の ガンだからもう悟らない
で ありがち順番で言えば
あの 例えば修行なんかする人にはアビッジャーなんかはね
そんなあるんだったら修行なんかに行かないんだからね
欲ばっかしで欲しいという病気だったらね
それから人を殺したいという
たまらないというんだったらね
修行道場なんか行く気はないしね
ですから それほどこの修行とかね
いいことをするという人々には
このとがそんなにガン化するということはない
まああります 恐れがありますけどね
突然ガン化になる可能性はありますけど
でもともう確実にある
その中でも番目のイダン・サッチャー・ヴィニレーサは
まあ随分あるんです ですから
すごく勉強しなくちゃいけないことなんです
そこは小さい時からこれだけなければ
世界でものすごい知識人になっちゃうんです
人間が頭が悪いのはこれのせいなんです
人間の中でこの天才みたいな人々は突然現れて
すごいことを貢献して死んじゃうでしょ
その人々っていうのは
この番目のこのガンは結構ないんです
だから天才っていうのはものすごい稀なもので
ないんです いないんですね
時々百年一人二人ぐらいは現れますけどね
ですから これ知って今はちょっと遅いかもしれませんだけど
この小さい時からはね
これは教え込まれて このがんの働きをね
教え込まれておくと もう抜群の知恵と知識をお持ちですね
イダンというのはこれは
サッチャっていうのは真実だ
これは真実だと アヴィニレーサ
頑固と信じて捕まって
その中に入っていって意味なんですね
いること で これは真相で言えば同じディッティなんです
見なんです 同じ見なんですが
まだ違う働きをする イダン・サッチャっていうのは
これは本物だ これは真実だ
これは事実だと自分の心で決めちゃうんです
決めちゃって まあその生き方で
その事実で それでずっともう自分の人生設計しちゃうんです
で 私たちの知識でいつでもそういうふうにいっちゃうんです
何か新しいニュース入れたら
あ そうですか 今そういうことですかと
もうそれは事実だと認めているんですね
聞いた瞬間に それで違うニュース入っちゃうと
まあもう捨てる まあそんなことはないんだと
[笑い]